antoine delorme arriva ambitieux mais
confiant au conseil des prud'hommes
c'est l'heure du rendu du jugement après
des mois de procédures et de mois de
délibéré mais à la sortie du bureau des
greffes c'est la douche froide il a été
débouté de toutes nos demandes
donc tous les dossiers ont été déboutés
en tout cas pour les caristes les douze
salariés n'ont pas vu leur statut de
cariste reconnu par le conseil des
prud'hommes une activité qu'ils disent
pourtant exercé pour certains depuis des
années une reconnaissance qui représente
environ 400 euros de plus par mois
les représentants d'amazon n'ont pas
souhaité répondre à une interview mais
il salue cette décision
nous sommes satisfaits de la position
adoptée par le conseil de prud'hommes de
chalon qui via confirmé une première
décision qui a statué en faveur d'
amazon sur cette même question
amazon fait ici référence un jugement
rendu en décembre 2018 à montélimar où
les salariés avaient effectivement perdu
nous en février dernier les prud'hommes
d'orléans avait condamné amazon pour les
mêmes questions pour maître thomas son
défenseur des salariés
dans ces deux affaires c'est
l'incompréhension est surprenant c'est
vrai quand vous avez un juge puis du
blanc et du noir c'est que manifestement
la question posée était plutôt bonne
fournit à mon sens repris mon pertinents
maintenant j'attends de comprendre
quelle a été la motivation bévues et
salariés débouté attendre maintenant la
notification du jugement pour connaître
les motivations des juges
quoi qu'il en soit ils n'entendent pas
en rester là le combat continue on ne
s'arrête pas là et on va faire valoir
nos droits on va prouver qu'on est reine
triste pour amazon ce jugement est bien
évidemment une victoire les salariés
honteux un mois pour faire appel de
cette décision